Good morning. Hank. It's Sunday. It's Riddle Sunday, the day that I answer real riddles from real nerdfighters.
Okay Hank, let's start. What gets wet while drying?
A towel.
What fastens two people yet touches only one?
A wedding ring.
Who's five six and a half, has a name that anagrams to "I pwn Harry Foe" and has fewer subscribers than us?
Hmm "Perry Fownhal?" "Fran Woiperry"?
"Harpo..."
Wait a second. You don't, you don't mean...
Yes.
No, not really.
Really!
Okay, really, do you mean it?
I'm getting very excited. Um, okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go to YouTube here on my trusty macbook pro.
I'm pulling up YouTube and
going to the most subscribed directors...
I'm seeing that the vlogbrothers have 41 818 subscribers
and Oprah has 41 365.
Now Hank, I am not an expert at pwning but that would seem to indicate that at least according to YouTube, we have pwned Oprah.
[Angelic noise]
Oh my gosh. I'm getting very excited. Uh...
But, you know, I have been wrong about mathematics before.
Remember that time that I thought that there were a hundred seconds in a minute?
Uhhh, I am definitely... I'm going to confirm this. I'm going to get some confirmation on this.
Okay Hank, I am now calling a brotherhood 2.0, resident mathematician,
Daniel Biss.
Hi, it's John Green. Do you have a minute?
(Daniel): I have a minute.
Okay, um your name is Daniel Biss
(Daniel): My name is Daniel Biss.
You are a professional mathematician.
(Daniel): This is correct.
Okay, um, you got your PhD from- from MIT, is that correct?
(Daniel): That is correct.
Okay. In your professional opinion, as a trained mathematician:
Is the number 41,818 larger than the number 41,365?
(Daniel): Yes.
YESSSSSS!
YESSSS
FROM A MATHEMATICIAN
YEEEEEEEAAAAAAAHH
WOOHOO
Yes! [Dog barking]
Even Willy's excited!
[Dog barking]
I know, Willy. There's a lot to be excited about. We pwned Oprah, we pwned Oprah.
I gotta call her Hank.
Hi, this is John Green of the vlogbrothers.
Um we just pwned Oprah. I'm not sure she's aware of it,
so I was calling to make sure that she knew. Oh, I figured that she'll want to call me back on account of how...
she was pwned. Um, but, uh, you know, I don't, I don't feel totally comfortable with giving Oprah MY phone number because
you know, I generally like to reserve my cell phone number for people who I have not yet pwned.
So if you could, just have her call me back through my agent Jodie Reamer at Writer's House.
Thanks very much, and as always, best wishes!
Hank, it's that rare occasion where puff levels are caused by unadulterated joy.
Hank, I can only say that it is a testament to the awesomeness of nerdfighteria
and a testament to the awesomeness of YOU that we have pwned Oprah on the most subscribed list.
This means, as previously agreed, that the nerdfighters get to punish us. Nerdfighters leave your punishment suggestions in comments.
I'm so excited about pwning Oprah that I've gotten sweaty and now my glasses are gonna fall off my face, but Hank, you are awesome.
...I almost said I love you, but then I held myself back. I'll see you soon.
PS. Nerdfighters, the details of Paper Towns tour dates are starting to be posted at eventful.com -  link in the sidebar or more likely, link in the sidebar,
I still can't do it.